there's a new season hair color that
everyone's talking about nepo blonde the
nepo babies are having a moment um yeah
fascinated with their lives their
relationships and now their hair color
So Pro Hair Stylist and Trend forecasted
Tom Smith flagged nepo blonde as one of
the Autumn hair colors to watch some of
the most high profile nepo baby Sofia
Richie Haley Bieber Kaya Gerber have
made the nepo Aesthetics synonymous with
quiet luxury and nepo blonde is pretty
much in keeping a lot of their looks are
kind of low-key but still Polished in
Luxe Tom describes nepo blonde as bright
clean and finally woven he recommends a
full head of funny woven highlights to
achieve that brightness but combined
with a really subtle Shadow root to keep
it a little more casual and Harriet
Muldoon at Larry King's Salon says the
key to getting an expensive looking
blonde is to adapt the shade to your
individual skin tone just like you would
with natural makeup so talk to your
colorist about your undertones to see
which blonde would hit best for you